[Music]
hello everybody I'm alone I'm a a
product manager in Google cloud and one
of the products that i am product
manager for is Google Cloud Data proc
and today I want to talk to you about
using the open source set of tools that
are in the Apache spark ecosystem to do
data processing on Google cloud platform
so we're going to talk about a few
things today first we're going to talk
about the tools themselves they're great
they bring a lot of benefits but they
also bring a lot of complexities and
headaches to talk about how we want to
solve that using hardware and software
innovations that are a part of Google
cloud platform I'm going to put my money
where my mouth is and do a live demo and
we're going to create a pretty big spark
and a dupe cluster to show you kind of
what we can do at scale some of the
speeds and some of the tools we have and
that we bring to the spark in Hadoop
ecosystem and then from there I want to
share a bunch of really new exciting
things that we just launched in
preparation for Google next so the first
thing that I want to talk about is the
complexity of the spark and dupe
ecosystem these tools are really really
great but they often bring a lot of kind
of painful headaches with them so
typically when you set up a spark in
Hadoop cluster it's not a sort of simple
or linear process if you are familiar
with setting up a spark in Hadoop
cluster on premise especially there's a
lot of steps involved you have to get
your hardware and configure that
hardware but that's only step one once
you have the hardware you then need to
get the open-source bits sometimes you
might do this vanilla or sometimes you
might use a Hadoop or spark vendor like
a cloud error horn works but then you
have to install that software and
configure it to knit and only really
after you're done with that are you
actually ready to start processing data
now if you wanted to use sparking the
dupe on day 0 or day one you're probably
not using sparking to do on day one with
this process it's probably taken days
weeks or months to actually get this
working properly there's even more
headaches if you actually want to set up
multiple clusters maybe cluster for
production cluster for development
so the scalene makes your life really
difficult so say you start off with a
cluster and you want to expand it
because you ran out of HDFS space which
is used to store data and spark in a
tube clusters well there's going to be a
lag of time between when you have the
capacity that you start with and have
the capacity that you need this also may
require you to actually take your
resources offline or have impaired
functionality probably your business or
the need to actually process your data
is not stopping for you while you're
actually scaling this cluster up you're
actually probably compounding matter and
some things are probably piling up that
you wish you could get to you also have
to really babysit utilization and this
is a really big problem especially for
accountants you're paying for a lot of
capacity but you're probably not running
your big data infrastructure at a
hundred percent all the time that means
that you're probably paying for over
capacity conversely you could pay for
under capacity but that's not really a
great solution either because then you
have less capacity than you actually
need to answer any of your questions so
you have to really be very careful about
how you plan out your capacity and try
and smooth out your you do utilization
as much as possible ultimately you're
not paying for what you use this is a
really big problem and one of the big
complaints of the spark in the duo bao
system or their great tools and oddly
enough a lot of its free open-source but
it can be very very costly to run and
maintain we don't want you to have this
problem sparking to dupe are great tools
and they bring a lot to the table but
you shouldn't worry about the cost and
complexity of running these tools to
take advantage of them so I did mention
quadrant Hortonworks if anybody in the
room is familiar with Claudia or
Hortonworks format bar and you're using
them just to throw out all three are
supported on Google cloud platform they
all have different ways to bootstrap
clusters so there's things like Cloudera
manager and Bari or Cloudbreak if you
want to use those in google cloud you
totally can and you get a lot of
benefits from doing that your pain is
going to get you know low pricing for
VMS you're going to be able to use cloud
storage you could possibly use cloud big
table instead of HBase so there's a lot
of benefits for doing that
just to say if you are tied to these or
really love these vendors you can
definitely bring them and lift and shift
them to Google cloud platform so we kind
of offer a suite of ways to run the
giant Apache and bark ecosystem and
that's maybe actually worth a note so
apache and sparkers sort of the two most
well-known components but it's a really
big ecosystem of kind of related tools
and I've never really found a better way
of referring to it other than the Apache
spark in Hadoop ecosystem so there's a
lot of tools that you can run on these
clusters and we have a whole host of
options to allow you to run the software
on cloud platform as I mentioned you
could take your on-premise or other
cloud Hadoop vendor and bring it to
Google cloud like a clutter hortonworks
we started off the journey with Cloud
Data proc which is a set of command-line
script they're open source and they're
on github and they allow you to
bootstrap kind of a lightweight sparking
to do cluster some of our large
customers actually started using with BD
util and have moved to data proc but if
you want to use Beauty to you till and
get started with a kind of lightweight
sparking to do cluster you totally can
but with cloud data properly thought we
could do better with BD you till you're
still kind of manually setting up the
cluster there's still little babysitting
you'd have to do it can be kind of
difficult to submit jobs for instance
you might have to use a command line to
do a lot of these things that might not
be a problem for some users but for your
average business user you probably don't
want them to have to use an SSH window
to actually our terminal window to go
interact with sparking to do clusters so
it's lot data properly really tried to
do a little bit better and focus on
everything except your data so we take
care of the infrastructure we take care
of the software you bring your data and
your jobs and you can use sparkin to
dupe without worrying about too much
else so there's a lot of open source
components as I mentioned and they map
to different google cloud products and
in different ways so a lot of these
these products you can run on Cloud Data
proc so if you're familiar with spud
with the Hadoop ecosystem quad data proc
uses yarn and a lot of the applications
in that ecosystem will run on yarn so if
you're using them you can generally come
and use cloud data proc we also have
other
services that are in their own ways tied
to some of these open source products
and I'll get to how they're tied in a
minute but for instance if you're using
HBase you might want to check out Claude
big table if you're interested in Apache
beam or crunch or flume quad data flow
is a really great solutions that you
might want to check out additionally if
you're tied to things like Impala or
century or HDFS we have products that
map to sort of all of these technologies
so Cloud Data proc handles I would say
the majority of them but around the
edges we also have a lot of projects and
fill in the gaps so I mentioned that
these products were all inspired by open
source technologies in different ways so
a lot of the open source ecosystem is
based on papers that google has released
throughout the years so for example the
relationship between big table and HBase
in other cases the open source ecosystem
has kind of evolved and of itself at
this point Google's also very actively
involved in contributing back to that
open source ecosystem a great example
being Apache beam which allows you to
create bachelor stream pipelines in kind
of one language with one sdk in one
model and run them on many different
routers whether it's cloud dataflow or
flank or spark so interestingly a lot of
the things that run on Cloud Data proc
were inspired by things that Google has
done in the past and a lot of things
that could run on data proc in the
future are inspired by goo things that
Google is doing in the present to try
and grow this ecosystem all together so
let's talk about cloud data proc just a
little bit more specifically so quadrado
proc is a way to create sparking to do
clusters that are generally fast low
cost and easy to use and the way that we
do that is we rely on a lot of the
things that the Google cloud platform
brings to the spark and a dupe ecosystem
and I'll talk about what things we rely
on but we've both tried to focus on
making the open source components run
really well and tuning some of them and
I can talk about that but also bring a
lot of the strengths of the Google cloud
platform to open source in the point I
make here is it's not about just
installing sparking to dupe on some
servers and calling it good
there's a lot of really deep
integrations optimizations and thought
that goes into making sparking to do
fast easy and cost-effective as an
example say you want a spark or Hadoop
cluster I started off with that really
long line of having rack servers and
configure servers but even if you don't
focus on that you still have to get the
open source software and tune it
customize it and debug it with Cloud
Data proc we want that process to be one
click we want you to be able to fill out
a very simple form and with one click
create your cluster Cloud Data proc is
interesting and i'll show it my demo we
don't extract away all of the
complexities knobs in the open source
ecosystem in some ways cloud data proc
is sort of an anti google cloud product
because we do expose that messiness to
you if you want it we don't necessarily
try and prevent you from doing bad
things we want you to know this is a
full-on spark and Hadoop cluster if you
want to tune specific properties or do
very specific customizations you totally
can we try and make it easy for you and
optimize as much as we can for you but
with a lot of these tools they're very
knobby and sometimes people want to tune
and poke those knobs and we totally let
you so if you want you can configure
your cluster and we have a set of tools
and API endpoints try and make that very
easy so that to take 20 seconds by 90
seconds or so you should have your
cluster so we go from possibly hours or
days or weeks to less than three or four
minutes as I mentioned what we're trying
to do is bring the open-source ecosystem
to Google cloud platform so we have a
lot of products and we don't want data
proc to just be isolated because having
just spark and Hadoop by itself isn't
super useful we want you to be able to
use spark in Hadoop with other products
we have in our platform and I have some
of them shown on the slide for example
you want you to be able to use sparking
a dupe with Google Cloud storage which
is a part of the demo as a replacement
for the Hadoop distributed file system
if you want to use big table we want you
to be able to use spark in the dupe with
big table same thing goes for bigquery
if you're using bigquery is an
enterprise data warehouse we want you to
be able to use that powerful enterprise
data warehouse with the really powerful
spark an idea be eco system
we tried to make it very easy focusing
on moving existing workloads to
Claudette aprox so generally sparkin de
doop has been out for a while and in one
way or another a lot of customers have
data and workloads that they want to
migrate we don't want that migration to
be painful generally that migration is
should be pretty easy you copy your data
step one to Google Cloud Storage step 2
you should be able to change just a few
lines of your job really the biggest
change you should need to make is just
changing the URI prefix of where your
data is located instead of being on HDFS
is in cloud storage you really shouldn't
need to make any other changes than that
so moving your actual code should be
very very easy almost as easy just
copying your data over and then step 3
you actually use cloud data proc so this
is an example job it's from the spark
examples and it's a job that is reading
from HDFS in this case you can see and
it may be hard to see and I apologize
hdfs is just stricken and we replace the
Rye prefix with GS for Google Cloud
Storage so if I wanted to move this
example job to data proc that's the only
change i need to make aside from making
sure that the data on reading exists in
cloud storage and has the same file
structure so again very very easy to
move work because moving moving work and
recoding things is not a value at you're
not focusing on your data we don't we
don't really want that under the hood a
little bit so Claude at aprox for all
intensive purposes a spark and Hadoop
cluster and you can create multiple
clusters in the project and submit work
to those clusters those clusters are
built on existing cloud platform
technology so it's built on compute
engine Claudia proc clusters have one or
more masternodes you have a set of
worker nodes and then you can create
pre-emptive worker nodes that take
advantage of pre-emptive all VMS for
anybody that's not familiar with
pre-emptive all VMS they're compute
engine VMs there are special type
there's a trade-off they have
substantially lower costs but they also
have a maximum lifetime of 24 hours
they're basically built on spare
capacity and
data centers and if we need that
capacity back you lose the preemptive
bull vm well pre-emptive all VMS may be
great for compute intensive workloads
with sparkin hadoop you can use them
with clawed at aprox just rely on the
lower general cost of Google cloud
platform but you allow you to use the
super low cost aspects of Google cloud
platform to bring your data processing
costs down even further clusters and
cloud data process attached to them
based on persistent disk we generally
advise customers don't actually store
any type of persistent data on this
because a you don't want your persistent
data to be ephemeral with your ephemeral
spark or Duke cluster and then be you
can actually get better performance
often with Google Cloud storage then you
can with HDFS that's based on persistent
disk and then with your clusters you can
read and write generally most customers
we use Google Cloud Storage to do that
going into a little bit more detail
Cloud Data proc has an API REST API and
our client tools talk to that rest api
that's the same REST API that anybody
anybody can use in the engineering team
which I have to give enormous credit to
their very passionate group of people
and I would not be able to actually talk
about Claudia to practice they weren't
dedicated to an awesome has put a lot of
time and thought into making that API
expressive yet easy to use that API
really have kind of three endpoints one
for managing clusters one for managing
jobs and there's an API endpoint for
operations so on all of these compute
nodes we have a cloud data proc which
talks to our control plane and this is a
lot this is really how we kind of create
the glue of the spark in the dupe
cluster and allow allow for some
interesting things like being able to
submit and manage work and interact with
yarn on the cluster we build an image
based on debian and the open source
components are built using another
Apache project called Apache big top so
basically we build our own custom sort
of open source distribution of the spark
on to do beco system if you haven't used
data proc before the team takes great
pride in making sure that we not only
version all of the versions of data prox
you can actually select kind of which
bundle of components you want to use and
their version set we also generally try
to release frequently so for example our
preview image for
cloud data proc is based on Hadoop 28
which is sort of late late and breaking
our production image right now uses very
recent versions of both Hadoop and spark
if you want to use older versions you
can always go back and use use older
versions of Cloud Data proc the goal
here is to allow people to use the set
of versions that they really want to and
not wag for weeks months or quarters
behind but also not just put beta
software on clusters and force people to
dog food so as I mentioned all of our
client tools are built on our REST API
generally there's three client tools or
three ways that people interact with
clusters there's the Google Cloud
console there's the Google Cloud SDK
which is often seen or known as g-cloud
and then there's SSH since this is built
on compute engines you can interact with
the compute nodes as if they were just
regular vm because they are so you can
ssh into the master and worker nodes
pricing a very common question for plot
data proc so with your cloud data
problem excuse me I shouldn't be able to
pronounce my own product them with your
cloud data proc cluster you pay for the
compute and storage charges that make up
your cluster and then there's a very low
one cent premium per virtual CPU on top
of that that we charge for all of the
awesome things we provide as part of
Cloud Data proc it sounds scary but
we're actually very cost effective if
you compare a cloud data proc to other
providers the source was actually moved
in this slide and I kind of have to duck
here but it's there it's actually based
on an o'reilly article to comparison
between amazon EMR and cloud data proc
and you can see in general cloud data
proc is runs jobs faster that's
important because we do by the minute we
don't round up to the nearest hour so if
you use a cluster for 13 minutes you pay
for 13 minutes not one hour we've also
really been optimizing Cloud Data proc
to make processing faster and this is a
really important point because the goal
is not to just let things stagnate we
actually want to speed up your data
processing workloads
it does mean that you might use less
cloud data proc and we actually see that
as a victory so this is an example of
feature which will be rolling out soon
to cloud data proc where we changed out
the SSL mechanism or provider used in
our cloud storage connector from the
default implementation to one based on
Google's fork of openssl I mean you can
see that reads have gotten or will get
in most cases substantially faster
rights will also see an improvement as
well I mean I mention this to really
showcase we're really trying to a goal
is to have you use less data proc
because you're able to do more with the
same amount or with less so the support
of components a big ecosystem there's a
lot of stuff that can you can run on
plot data proc clusters by default we
install the most common packages so
that's spark Hadoop hive pig some of
those packages are tricky because
something like Hadoop includes I don't
know how many weird slept sub-projects
and tangents of projects but generally
those are the four core components we
build a lot of the ecosystem however in
big top we have a repository with each
release so if you wanted to install
something like Zeppelin that's built in
big top it's actually in big top so if
you went on to a cluster or you used an
initialization action which I will show
you my demo you could install Zeppelin's
we actually have pre-built it the reason
i call this out it's a very common
question of how much can we install on a
cluster well you can install really
whatever you want we try to keep it lean
because we don't want to burden clusters
and install stuff that people aren't
going to use and is just going to take
up resources and make their data
processing slower and make them sad and
then that makes upset so I'm going to go
to a cloud data proc demo to tie
together some of the things that I've
mentioned thus far in this demo we're
going to do a few things we are going to
create a cluster and I'm going to create
a fairly sizable cluster it's not the
biggest cluster in the world but i think
it's it's you know modestly big we're
going to query a large set of data and
i'll talk about the data and the queries
that we're going to run we're going to
see the output of those queries and that
actually hints some of the really fancy
tooling around quad at aprox
and then we're going to delete the
cluster just to show you that you only
need the cluster that's really designed
as an ephemeral solution you only need
the cluster as long as you actually have
data to process so the data that we are
going to query is based on the New York
taxi data set so from 2009 to 2015 new
york city limousine taxi Commission
released all taxi trips and uber trips
in New York uncompressed the data set is
about 270 gigabytes it's in CSV format
there's about 1.2 billion trips in this
data set so I'm going to switch here so
this is the google cloud console if you
have not seen it before and this is the
form or the page to create a cloud data
proc cluster I could create this cluster
through just a raw API call I could also
use g-cloud i'm showing you through the
cloud console just because it is
generally the least it's much easier to
demo than trying to type in a console
first thing we're going to do is give
the cluster a name I'm going to call my
cluster James demo the second thing that
you generally will want to fill in is
the zone where you're going to create a
cluster quad data proc is generally
available wherever compute engine is
available that is going to be true as
compute engine is made available in more
regions as Google Cloud expands the quad
at approxi- be available everywhere that
Google cloud is available so right now
the list is here and the list will grow
over time I'm going to choose us central
just because I suspect that's going to
give us pretty good performance since
we're in the u.s. right now you then
choose how you want to configure your
master and worker nodes and these are
very analogous to traditional Hadoop
master and worker nodes for masternodes
we offer kind of three different
varieties and one of them is actually a
new feature which is having a cluster
that's just one node that means your
master is your worker good for
development exploration possible
education lightweight data science the
default option is just having one master
we also offer the ability to have high
availability which is three masters and
that provides it's based on zookeeper
and it provides yarn and HDFS high
availability I'm just going to create a
standard
cluster here because we don't need high
availability you can choose the machine
type that you want to use in your
cluster in the web UI here we have all
of the standard non-shared cpu machine
types you can also use custom VMs with
Cloud Data proc so if you actually
wanted to use a machine type that was
based on six cpus and 58.6 two gigabytes
of ram you could absolutely do that
through the API and the command line in
this case I'm just going to choose an N
one standard 16 for my master node and
worker notes same thing something that
is worth calling out here is in the very
near future Cloud Data proc will be
supporting 64 core vm which were
recently announced on beta on google
cloud platform and I call that out
because often a lot of the improvements
that are made to the underlying services
of cloud platform whether it's compute
engine or cloud storage or networking
Cloud Data proc so as a lot of other
components from google cloud get better
it means that using sparkin to do gets
incrementing the way better as well for
my worker nodes i'm going to use an
eight-core n1 standard 8 just in our
testing these work usually pretty well
I'm going to go ahead and create kind of
a modestly large cluster here let's go
ahead and add 200 notes that will give
us 1,600 yarn cores and about 4.7
terabytes of yarn ram we're not going to
use a lot of HDFS so I'm actually going
to lower the amount of persistent disk
that we attach because we're not really
going to be writing to HDFS and then you
can see there's some advanced options
that are optional that you can configure
I could do things like use networking
and Claudia proc supports a wide variety
of networking options you can select as
i mention different versions of cloud
data proc in this case the configuration
i'm going to apply is I'm really going
to the one to notice I'm going to
install presto mi cluster just to show
you that you can install a wide variety
of things on Cloud Data proc and presto
is actually not part of the sort of
Apache Big Data ecosystem but I'm going
to install it and show you that it works
and we're going to run all of our
queries through presto actually so we'll
go ahead and create that cluster
right so the cluster is in the process
of bootstrapping itself let's go ahead
and fill out the form to submit our job
now with Cloud Data proc one of the
things that we've paid a lot of
attention to is trying to make it really
easy to interact with your cluster and
often when you want to submit work in
this case we call them jobs two clusters
you have to use kind of complicated too
willing or yaps like login and openssh
window and that's just no good if you're
if you have a lot of work to do we want
it to be very easy for you to submit
your spark or PI spark or spark SQL
scripts to cloud data proc the other
thing that I'll show you here is the
jobs API and the tools on top of it
allow us to not only submit work but we
can actually see the streamed output
from those jobs and the nice thing is is
I could actually submit the job and
close my computer and throw it in a fire
and that job is still going to run so
it's not tied to the persistence of that
one computer which is actually a really
annoying problem if you use spark and
Hadoop alot that you open up a terminal
window and if the terminal window goes
away unless you thought about it that
job is going to just vanish when you
when you leave your career so first
thing I'm going to choose the cluster
that I want to run the job on the next
thing I'm going to do is choose the job
type right now we support six job types
I'm going to run pig and people always
give me a hard time about this but
there's a very good reason the reason
i'm going to use pig is because i'm
going to abuse big I'm actually just
going to use pig to shell out to call
presto a little convoluted but it's
convoluted on purpose to show you that
we're not putting up like bumpers or
guardrails you can do really whatever
you want the goal here is to allow you
to have life be very easy so for example
if I wanted to just run spark SQL I
could enter a file with my spark SQL and
cloud storage or just the raw query text
like very easy in me using pig to shell
out to presto it's a bit more
complicated and interesting but that's
really to show you that if you want to
develop with sparking to do we're not
going to try and artificially limit you
and constrained you too much
so with my Pig script here i am going to
specify my query file which is inside of
a cloud storage bucket in this SQL
script is going to essentially just
query presto with a few queries let's go
take a look at the cluster that we
created I was talking a little bit
unfortunately and just blabbering a lot
my cluster actually was ready probably
two minutes ago so our two hundred node
cluster with 1,600 cores is ready to go
all the VMS r up and it's ready to take
work if i wanted to i can edit this
cluster and do things like add and
remove worker nodes i can add and remove
pre-emptive all notes so and that's why
the cluster is running so if i wanted to
add more notes to this cholesterol was
running I totally can and just because
it sounds like fun let's go ahead and do
that so let's submit our job and the job
is now running on my cluster and as the
job gets started you'll actually see the
job output start spooling here live to
the screen so you can actually see that
first thing that's going to happen if
you have really good eyesight is we're
going to create a external table and
then start running queries against that
external table this is an example of us
trying to make life easy for you so the
job was sent to the cluster or
interacting with open source components
from feeding the output back to you jobs
running let's go ahead and say oh I'm
worried about this job let's go ahead
and add you know 20 more nodes or 10
more notes just because we want a really
big cluster so we're going to go ahead
and update the cluster while the job is
running it's not going to impact the job
at all and you can see that the job is
starting to school output to this screen
live it's going to update the same you'd
have the same experience if you used the
g-cloud command so if you said gee Cloud
Data proc job submit pig and then set it
to required arguments you're going to
see this output to the screen as well
this job is not writing anything
anywhere it's really just emitting the
results in standard out you obviously
could save results back to you know
bigquery or cloud storage or a number of
other cloud products
you can see that while the cluster is
resizing it doesn't go down there's no
interruption of service it just
continues to work without hassle without
you needing to do anything much more
specific than that so will that job up
okay I was going to actually start
talking again but we just went and
queried all of that data it took a
minute and 33 seconds what's really
impressive about that is this data is in
cloud storage so between cloud storage
or this giant data set is stored and the
spark and adieu cluster it was able to
read the data and query it in one minute
and 33 seconds and that's really because
there's really fast networking between
well in our data centers in general and
the cloud data proc cluster is able to
use that really fast networking to go
query cloud storage in a jiffy so
actually we're just done with this
cluster that's really what I wanted to
show so let's go ahead and say we're
done we actually don't need this cluster
anymore we'll just go ahead and delete
that cluster and the cluster is going to
go away no fuss no hassle so what
happened we created a cluster with 1,600
yarn cores it ran the spark medupe
ecosystem in this case we took advantage
of presto and we did it in one click to
put a little bit more detail in what we
did we created an external table that
was based on the data in the cloud
storage bucket and then we just ran a
few simple queries against that data
these aren't the most complicated
queries in the world but it is reading a
substantial portion of the data from
cloud storage using presto ultimately
and I've run this demo enough sand run
the cost on all these different clouds
we didn't have this cluster for longer
than 10 minutes so we're going to
actually be charged the 10 minute
minimum for cloud data proc everything
beyond 10 minutes is per minute that 210
node cluster costs twelve dollars and
eighty-five cents to run if you ran it
in amazon EMR or HD insight you'd be
paying substantially more respectively
just based on either our rounding or
just more expensive coughs on a
permanent basis overall
so I've told you data proc is awesome we
have some just kind of random random
quotes from Twitter if you don't believe
me you can search twitter these are
definitely there we've you had both
customers offloaded from other clouds to
data proc or from on-premise to data
proc and we've really tried to focus on
customer feedback to make dat aprox
better that's a core part of how we
improve the platform overall ultimately
we also try to share best practices with
customers to make using data proc easier
and I want to share kind of some of
those tips with you so if you are
interested in using spark in the DuPont
cloud platform or you are using cloud
data proc you have a better experience
the first tips that we recommend to a
lot of customers is to split clusters
and jobs canonically on-premise you most
often will have one cluster and
everybody will just submit all of their
jobs to that cluster and they may try
and do it intelligently and submit their
jobs over time or schedule them or they
may just submit all of the jobs and see
what happens with cloud data protocol
clusters and the clusters can be right
sized and shaped and conditioned and
configured to run specific types of jobs
so if I have a bunch of jobs and my
first two jobs run pretty quickly and I
know I can run them in parallel I can
send them off to cluster a if I have two
slower jobs that are very intensive and
I want them to run separately you can
run them on separate clusters we also
support the use of cloud labels with
quadratic rock labels are a key value
key value pair that you can associate
with cloud resources with quad at
approximant clusters and I wanted to tag
maybe organization equals a B and C I
can then do cost accounting and billing
accounting based on those labels and
actually filter and list by those labels
separately so if you are running
sparking to do in an enterprise setting
and you actually wanted to do something
like be able to figure out how much
people were using or trace that back
label to make it very easy and splitting
clusters and jobs makes it very easy and
labels can apply to both cloud data
Proctor's and jobs
development and production if you need
to have a production in development
environment you want to have maybe a
staging environment since you can have
multiple clusters it's very easy to have
separate prod dev tests whatever
experimentation clusters you just create
a new cluster nice thing here is if for
example you want to do some development
and you didn't want to break or impact
other users or other jobs just create a
development cluster additionally since
you can read data for instance from
cloud storage from multiple different
clusters if I wanted to have all of my
production work occurring and then do
some development maybe I have a bunch of
spark and I want to test it and spark 22
you can create a new cluster use a
preview image and start testing against
that cloud storage bucket you don't have
to do anything differently you don't
have to copy data it's very easy to do
and we've had a lot of success trying to
help customers migrate so the idea that
you can create clusters when you need
them and if you don't need them you can
delete them there's really no reason
honestly to I would advocate if you're
not using a cluster delete it we don't
want you to keep it around we don't
that's not good for you and ultimately
that just makes it not good for us so
create and delete clusters often if you
have a bunch of work can you want to
schedule creating and deleting clusters
you can as an example if you are using
something like Apache air flow you can
actually create quad 80 prot clusters
run your jobs using apache air flow and
then delete your cluster a great example
of an ephemeral use case where you can
create and delete clusters often just
based on whatever you actually need them
cloud storage a lot of people that shift
from on-premise to to cloud data proc
ask us you know what's the performance
of cloud storage how does it compare
with HDFS why should I use cloud storage
generally speaking cloud storage is
going to give you a very high throughput
it has its own sets of features which
you may find really useful like being
able to apply security controls are
having auditing on cloud storage buckets
it also allows you to use data and cloud
storage between many different google
cloud products you could do like
federated queries with bigquery on that
cloud storage bucket so moving away from
HDFS not only brings performance and
cost benefits for your spark in a new
piece cases but it may provide a lot
about other benefits
for data that would normally have just
been living in HDFS because that's where
it would live the job submission API if
you are submitting work to your clusters
I mean you can submit work really many
different ways there's probably an
infinite number of ways when you look at
it to submit work you could SSH in and
use sparks MIT you could use something
like air flow you could write a Python
script that's sitting on a crontab just
submitting work whenever you know
whatever you have a schedule generally
we advocate that you use our job
submission API and there's a lot of
reasons for that it allows you to do
things like apply labels to jobs as you
saw you can see the output from jobs it
makes it much easier so you only have to
fill in a few arguments to actually
submit work to a cluster so with a job
API we've really tried to make it easy
for you to broker work and interact with
work and manage work with clusters so as
I've sort of shown you and talked about
you can scale clusters at any time we
scaled the cluster in the demo as i
mentioned i didn't demo it but you can
use custom vm types for your master and
worker nodes and you can use pre-emptive
bull notes with your clusters if you
want to use printable nodes one thing
that I ran to install presto is what i
call the initialization action
initialization actions are scripts which
can be interpreted on the cluster so
these could be shell scripts they could
be Python scripts they could be Ruby
script these scripts are run after the
services start on the cluster they're
really useful for doing things like
staging jars or copying data locally of
you might want to test on or in this
case as we saw installing presto we also
have mechanisms through our client
tooling to allow you to set properties
in cluster files so if you wanted to
modify say properties in the course ID
XML file we have a way for you to easily
do that you don't have to go in and ssh
in or write an initialization action to
do it so we've tried to create two
really powerful but easy ways for you to
customize clusters when you start them
up there's a bunch of new cloud data
proc features that I want to talk about
that we've released kind of in the last
few weeks and anticipation for next
we've actually gotten a few more out
that I I can talk about as well the
first is restartable
old jobs so in our job API and our
client tooling traditionally when a job
ran and failed that was sort of it the
job would just sit and have failed in
some cases this may not be desirable you
actually may want a job to restart for
example you may have a streaming job
that just runs out of memory and it was
a kind of a corner case and you want
that job to restart with our client
tooling now when you submit a job to
Cloud Data proc you can actually specify
the number of times per hour that you
want that job to restart this is really
useful for long-running jobs we designed
it with kind of an eye on streaming
applications as we look to better
support and provide support for
streaming applications on day rock so
that way you can be confident that if
your work fails we're going to wreak ick
off that job for you GPUs were recently
announced on cloud platform and made
available to compute engine this is a
good example of when innovations occur
on other parts of the cloud platform if
they make sense to bring to the spark in
Hadoop ecosystem we absolutely want to
so when you create claw data proc
clusters now you can specify the number
of accelerators which are essentially
GPUs that you want attached to either
your master or worker nodes in your
cluster from zero which is the default
up to eight be you know if anybody is
really interested in GPUs in spark I
think you would probably know this is an
evolving ecosystem and I think the spark
support and kind of other ecosystem
support for GPUs as an evolving story
but there's a lot of cases we actually
may want to use GPUs now or in the
future and it was very important to us
to allow you to use them with Cloud Data
pockets as soon as possible I briefly
mentioned single node clusters a common
request that we had from customers was
they wanted to just run very small tests
and they'd actually didn't need a
full-blown cluster so they just wanted
to run a really quick test using spark
so they wanted to do really lightweight
data science with single node clusters
you create a cluster which is just one
node it's the master and worker nodes
that way you don't have to create a
full-blown spark in a noob cluster
because for something like if you're
teaching somebody how you're leading a
class for example on how to use
mark you don't need giant clusters to do
that you actually just need probably a
small issue vm that has bark installed
and with single node clusters you've
really tried to make it easy for you to
create these lightweight clusters for
experimentation development regional
endpoints and private IP addresses so
with quad data proc when we launched
almost a year ago our API and the client
tools user api used one region which was
global recently we've added individual
regions for each compute engine region
and clawed at aprox and via our client
tools you can now isolate to a specific
region so you could say if you're using
our tools say keep ever you know use the
u.s. region that means the calls are
going to that region we've distributed
our control plane and essentially we've
stood up individual stacks of the
control infrastructure for cloud data
proc in all of these individual regions
the benefit there is you may get better
performance so for example if you are in
Europe and you wanted to use the Europe
region you may get much better
performance by isolating to that region
for applications that are working
entirely in Europe clusters and cloud
resources have going to private eye peas
clusters and resources have often had
public IPS attached to them one very
very common request from large
enterprise customers especially was I
want clusters but I don't want them to
have a public IP attached because that
makes my security people very sad face
so with the recent launch of Claude pass
last week we now support creating
clusters that do not have a public IP
attached to them and an important
differentiator here is we try and make
it very easy so it's not you know this
isn't something that's unique to data
proc but the way that we've tried to
innovate and make life better for all
Google cloud customers here is to make
it very easy to create clusters that
don't have a public IP attached to them
both of these features are in beta and
yeah there they were both commonly
requested features and night drives back
to we try to respond to customer
feedback so honestly if you are
interested in using data proper you are
and you have ideas request gripes loves
complaints you know send them our way we
try to be very very customer focused and
hands-on how would it get started with
cloud data proc there's a few different
sessions which either directly or
indirectly mentioned cloud data proc
some of these sessions have
unfortunately already passed but the
good news is is I believe the videos
will be on YouTube so if you are
interested this was kind of the most to
level set this is really just kind of
the introduction to a lot of these
concepts a lot of these other tools go
into very specific ideas and concepts if
you want to get hands-on literally right
now there's a ton of code labs
downstairs you can get started with
cloud data proxy labs we also have a set
of quick starts and tutorials to show
you how to create clusters and submit
jobs and just to sort of go back to the
initialization actions a lot of what we
do that's customer facing that's open
source we have in various github
repositories so we have our
initialization actions for example for
installing like Zeppelin and presto
there if you need help there's many
different ways you can get help with
Cloud Data proc we have documentation
online we also have our release notes I
again have to give the engineering team
credit here we release updates to Cloud
Data proc saraly frequently which we
really take pride in we're trying to
bring the latest and greatest of this
large ecosystem with a ton of
innovations to make it better so if you
have been or are interested in data proc
watch our release notes pretty closely
because they usually will change about
every week for the better if you
actually want you know hands-on help a
really good place is stack overflow
using the Google Cloud Data proc tag you
could probably indirectly meet many
members of the cloud data proc on just
answers from stack overflow and then we
have our informal email list and if you
are a google cloud support customers
that's also an option as well and with
that if there's any questions I'm happy
to take that other than that thank you
guys very much
[Music]
[Music]